see it's interesting because i don't
believe in soul mates at all okay
okay but can i ask okay yeah i think
this is your podcast like you have told
me before that you're very religious so
how does that relate to your religious
beliefs that you don't believe in like
soul mates well i think religion
it comes down to choices so if i started
let's say i started and only fans
tomorrow would that change the type of
husband i get no no i think it does i
think your choices affect like the type
of person that's the right i feel like
the right person for you could look past
that [ __ ] and
sorry stuff
the right man it may and when i say the
right man i'm not saying that it's like
a man like a man could be one way with
you and a different way with another
girl that's right for them so the right
man for you would be able to look past
that and that's all i'll say so if i
started porn tomorrow i can't say that
on youtube corn
tomorrow you think the right man should
just look look past that if he's your
the right person for you yes 100 he
should be no i i really think it's your
choice but what about in life if you
start doing corn yeah but what if that
is like
you have lived a life and this is a way
for you to make money and provide for
yourself or
vice versa you never know someone's
story
right you know what i'm saying and there
are people that just do it you know
everyone's different but like
you know
if
if that's what you did to provide or
just to survive or you went through
certain things in your life that have
made you be hypersexual
and whatnot well i mean
the thing is i know i've lived like i
you know i had a very sheltered like
childhood so i'm in a situation where
like
you know i'm not going to judge someone
for what they've had to do when i like
haven't had to like struggle like that
you know but
at the same time like it's going to be
your future husband starts off as a
complete stranger so how is he supposed
to not judge you when he doesn't know
you
well i think that also depends on like
for example if you're somebody who
would never resort to that
you're probably going to look for a
partner who wouldn't be with someone who
would respond to that right but that's
why i think it comes back to like the
choices you make or the that's the type
of partner you end up with yeah because
i think like you want someone with the
same values as you
so but does doing like
sex work per se
there are values and morals like
personally that's not something i would
do right
personally
but when i look at other people that
do that kind of stuff i don't say
well
what are your morals and what are your
values i've more more so think of what
brought you to this point in your life
to where you felt that you had to
well there's a difference like there's
some people who just do it because they
don't give a sh
sorry yeah but you know there's also
people that do a lot of girls do it
because they feel like they don't have
another option
okay i'll ask you guys would you guys
date a girl would you marry a girl
mother of your children
who has done corn
i want you to go first
come
listen
i agree with um
both of what you're saying to be honest
but i follow more so
what pearl's saying we all have choices
like you can be from
a poor background and still be
successful you could choose
a life that's
makes you a bad quote-unquote bad
citizen
or you can
choose bad citizens that's a strong word
very bad
think about it you don't have to be a
sex worker you there's so many things
but but exactly what about sex work
think about it your body if you think
about it your body we're talking about
we're talking about
soul ties right now
giving yourself to multiple people
here and there you don't think you're
getting soul ties from that but but in
what way are you talking about
physically or just over like uh
it's different with physically and then
emotionally as well you can give
yourself to someone
physically but you never gave them to
emotion it's quite different in my
opinion okay also let's talk about the
fact that this whole
world of of only fans and whatnot was
the consumers are men
it's not women it's men and women have
been over sexualized throughout their
life and
have been you know we sexualize
ourselves uh i'm sorry
that's not true because no it's not no
it's not because we grow up in a society
that that tells you like men will want
you if you are a certain type of way
right so like
okay like sex work women wouldn't do
that if men weren't like that that's
them capitalizing on the entire both
sides but at least but we have a backup
plan like if a man is broke he's broken
homeless like
you don't see them like coming also
the whole this world is run by
privileged white men women didn't
couldn't even vote until what i don't
even know
why don't we bring it and i agree
but what is it awesome because it's
getting too wonderful
your followers are going to be what does
that mean
i feel like it's a bit of combo like you
you still have to make your choices by
yourself you don't have to do you don't
have to do certain things that you don't
want to do so even though
quote-unquote men's
sexualized woman this and that there's a
lot of smart women who know this
and use it to their advantages to get in
spaces
where they can gain resources resources
to boss upon these men
you don't have to you know no that's
fact that's bad yeah how you're saying
it's like you're saying that they have
no choice no i'm saying that let's not
judge women that are brought to that
point that's what i'm saying
no one brings you to a point
you have a choice everything in life is
a choice
okay
and i'm talking for the women who feel
like they haven't had a choice in that
situation so you're talking about
everything life is a choice but there
are genuinely women who throughout their
life have not been shown
how to value themselves other than their
sexuality right their body that is their
commodity so if that is their way of
surviving in a very harsh world for a
lot of people a lot of women
specifically and that's how they provide
then who's to judge
that's and again
let me shut up but it's not it's not
judging to say i wouldn't marry that
person that's your own yeah that's what
i'm saying like i think men have a right
to be selective in who they date
and marry yeah and so i don't think that
like we're entitled to their
understanding
you know what i mean like i think
that
like there's a difference between saying
i wouldn't date that person and you know
saying you're a terrible person because
that's what you had to do i feel like
there's also a difference though like
for example
i have someone in my family who started
doing sex work
only fans because she wanted some extra
money but she didn't need it yeah she
had a place to live that's i feel like
that is a different situation my opinion
on that is completely different rather
than someone who literally is just
trying to survive right i just think you
can't pay for my own fans
[Music]
this guy is one-on-one
yo juice
okay wait pause for a second um
that's what i was about to say